part of you guys seen the amazing
spider-man by now if not probably should
before you watch this heavy spoiler
video here for the amazing spider-man 2
so let's get into it because you guys
have been asking for a spoiler video
would I put my video up but first of all
first thing to note I am a huge
spider-man fan he's so awesome and
relatable and smart and spider-man is
[ __ ] talker he swings around on webs
it's just nothing not to like about it
and granted maybe that's why I found
some of the things in this movie
irritating I try to separate my fanboy
isms when I watch a movie do you want to
separate that me like okay how is it as
a movie cuz in the end it comes down to
execution and what did they use and what
did they waste that just has to do with
the movie itself first of all it's
really funny the first guy that he takes
down is the Ryan L before he's the right
now Paul Giamatti who's just big Russian
cartoon he's going around and shooting
his machine gun he takes him down and I
was like right I thought he was gonna
fight the Rhino at the very beginning
but it's just Paul Giamatti
it's him before he's the Rhino which
where's the Rhino so I thought maybe
he'll come into play later and he does
about two hours and 15 minutes later we
saw Jamie Foxx in the trailer he's a big
spider-man stalker he'll we saw most of
the movies in all the trailers I like
that Time Square scene when you sappin
the power and I thought the trailer
makes it looks like he just dicks out to
start shooting spider-man but at first
he's so scared out of his mind he's new
power he's he's electric he's stepping
in the rain it's arcing cops are getting
a little trigger-finger like but I love
this scene when he comes on the screen
because like everyone has their cameras
on him so he's in all the TVs in Times
Square and he's looking around he was
like oh that's cool
even though it's not good for him he's
is clearly a problem but he thought it
was great he's somebody now he's on the
big screen then the cameras go towards
spider-man he gets irritated and pissed
out of the ego and that's when he starts
freaking out it's a big fight I just
like that whole conflict
it shows what Electro's like how he
thinks how he acts he actually gave some
character to Elektra which is miles
ahead of what they did with dr. Connors
in the last movie and it feeds into the
fact that spider-man is so smart I know
some of you a lot of you a number of you
point is there are people who are like
no Tobey Maguire is the best spider-man
and Tobey Maguire's fine but he's so
average the thing is in those Raimi
movies I cannot tell you that Tobey
Maguire's spider-man has an
above-average IQ spider-man is supposed
to be an average dude but he is supposed
to be so smart Peter Parker so smart I
feel the Marc Webb Andrew Garfield
spider-man shows that a lot more electro
shorts out his web-shooters and I was
like how is he gonna take him on now so
there's a scene where he's trying to
ground the web-shooter so electricity
isn't frying but that was
awesome i'll sikita spider-man in his
brain I really like the electro song
every time it came on I was like that
song is awesome I love it when a villain
has a theme that song the one it's in
the trailer it's all like it's an
awesome song it's just creepy and I was
listening to it the entire ride home on
YouTube Thank You YouTube for having
music although speaking of paranoia when
electro is in Times Square you can hear
voices in his head and I was like okay
how many villains in spider-man are
going to have voices in their head Green
Goblin talked to himself Doctor Octopus
the arms would talk to him the lizard
had voices in his head electro
apparently has voices in his head in one
scene spider-man just needs to give
these folks a pill and they'll be fine I
like the Easter eggs in the movie too
when Max calls that one dude mr. Smythe
I was like whoa Alistair Smythe holy
[ __ ]
PJ Novak plays Alistair Smythe Rose is
one chick she plays black cattle not
really black a she plays Felicia Felicia
actually becomes black cat' these little
things that they have in the movie
showing that in his spider-man's
universe but these people aren't
anything yeah they're just kind of there
they should be there because they become
relevant in spider-man even if they
don't in any of the movies I like to
know that Felicia and Alistair Smythe
they're in the universe and that's cool
too mesh means bad boy Ben Riley's out
there somewhere so while electro is
hanging out and he's like getting dunked
in a tank and fried Peter Parker starts
reconnecting with his friend Harry
Osborn at least his childhood friend at
first was like okay so they were friends
it's not like they first met in this
movie it's fine if they're building up
to like the third movie where he becomes
the Goblin but let's say they're gonna
shoe horn the Goblin into this movie I'm
not really gonna be as connected with
the situation cuz you don't see their
friendship grow just like oh hey how's
it going pal alright let's skip some
rocks right now I hate your guts and
this is pretty much what they do and
that one scene a dialogue where he's
like Oscorp had you under surveillance
why isn't that the question of the day
yeah that's a scene is just gone not in
the movie anymore that's just this toast
which makes me think back to the amazing
spider-man one where they took a lot of
stuff out of there and I'm like this
Marc Webb just make movies that get
sliced up branded things end up on the
cutting room floor in movies that's just
the way it goes but you feel like when
they make the trailers they have an idea
of what they're gonna keep in the movie
and what they're gonna toast my favorite
gwen stacy Peter Parker scenes a scene
where they're talking is like alright
stop doing that thing with your nose was
the way too cute it's killing me and
you're watching it you're like you guys
are a cute couple it's on-again
off-again [ __ ] I've seen that a
hundred times in movies before but you
guys are cute so why not just date
she'll be around for a long time anyway
I write and the green Goblin's in this
movie to kind of well it's Harry Osborn
it's not Norman Osborn I've heard some
of the comic books did that they just
went right to Harry and skip Norman
which could be cool I feel like that
would be better if Norman was around for
it Norman Osborn dies after three
minutes of screen time Norman's around
for his kid to be the Goblin I don't
know maybe he can be like well finally
you're doing something with your life or
you're being a dick or you're not my son
anymore or hey let's do it together I
don't know something other than just
killing him off but yeah he dies after a
couple minutes and people have said like
no he's actually the Goblin his skin's
green he has long nails he is the Green
Goblin technically I would argue that I
would say no he's actually not he's just
an old guy with green skin and long now
he would be the Green Goblin if he did
the Green Goblin things see to me a
character is more than just how he looks
is his general persona and his action
that's not who we are on the inside is
what we do that defines us I don't know
someone said that however Harry becomes
a goblin I was gonna throw down with the
Green Goblin is there for a couple of
minutes and then he gets taken down
after the big Throwdown with electro the
Green Goblin comes in to cause some
problems he's there clearly to kill Gwen
Stacy yeah she dies do you feel like
when they're right in the movie they
were like well Gwen Stacy should die in
this one because we don't want her
around for the sinister six things so
let's just kill her now but in order to
kill her we got to make the Goblin do it
because the Goblin kills are in the
comics so we're just going to have them
in here just a killer it's not even from
a comic book standpoint is that wasting
a comic book character but any character
whatsoever in most any movie that just
becomes a villain out of the blue near
the end and then is in the movie at the
end as the villain just to do one thing
before he gets taken out it feels that a
place it doesn't really float the movie
right and he'll be in the next movie I'm
sure but for his big introduction don't
have him in here for a couple minutes
and that's when I backed up and I was
like this feels a lot like venom in
spider-man 3 think about it in
spider-man 3 there were whispers that
venom might be in it and in one trailer
you thought you saw him once or twice
you're like jaws I think that was venom
did in the last trailer you saw him
fighting with spider-man a couple times
never look up Venom's in the movie and
he fights with spider-man
didn't you watch the movie and you're
like oh and he's in the last part of the
movie for one fight and then he gets
taken down and it felt out of place
you're like that what a waste of venom
the exact same feeling is what I got
with the Green Goblin in this movie from
the marketing to execution did the two
are very similar situations that walked
out of the movie theater going I thought
we were supposed to learn from
spider-man 3 not repeat some of the
mistakes granted this movies a lot
better than spider-man 3 I'm not saying
it is spider-man 3 but there are some
things you need to address and go that
just wasn't handled well okay Gwen Stacy
fall is my favorite scene in the movie
spider-man shoots the web and you know
what's coming you're like Shia gosh this
is gonna suck ass the web is coming for
her and you know in the comic book
spider-man webs her footing it breaks
her neck the momentum just snaps her
neck this one was she was falling the
web got her but it was a build a second
too late and it snaps her neck back and
with the full force of the momentum she
smacks her head in the concrete you're
like oh oh I think she's dead it made me
feel ill I was like who uh spider-man
goes down there and he was like Gwen
Gwen I'm pretty sure she smacked her
head on the pavement it might just be
the whiplash snapped her neck but I'm
pretty sure she landed above the ground
but the whiplash smacked her head on the
ground and she's just dead now the only
thing I call [ __ ] on on that is the
fact that her head didn't look like a
crushed meatball did spider-man gets
down there and Peter Parker's just
crying and she's bleeding out of her
nose and you're like that's rough not
gonna live that scene actually got to me
it was emotional it chokes me up a bit
and that's when I was like all right the
movie has a hole I'll forgive the Goblin
thing and this is a positive movie but
then you montage through the course of I
think it was about a year or a few
seasons where Peter Parker's just
sitting there at her grave and you see
like summer fall winter spring [ __ ] he's
sulking for a while spider-man's been
gone I wish they'd ended the movie there
where it's like spider-man is gone and
in the next movie the sinister six
happens and now spider-man's back
because that's what brings him out of
retirement but now the rhinos in his
costume talking in his big Russian
cartoon voice and spider-man I swear to
you the last scene is in the trailer
whenever they show the last shot of the
movie I'm always like you sure the last
chatter though you don't know it's the
last shot of the movie when you're
watching the trailer all the times in
trailers you can assess it though be
like it's probably the last shot they do
you finally identify the really
mysterious guy who's gathering the
sinister sex he's mr. fears he's the
gentleman and I was like I know that
name and that's because I read the book
gathering of the sinister six and that's
what he's from he's a dude who works
with the chameleon to gather the
sinister six although he was kind of
like evil
Alfred the butler and that one this one
he's kind of a creepy guy it looks like
Van Damme boy he is who he is so now we
know in the end the amazing spider-man 2
I felt good have been better if they had
Paul Giamatti in the beginning and then
he fights electro and a lot of the back
and forth love story things were cut out
and he was just like yeah I'm dating you
and now you're dead and you're dead from
a means other than the Green Goblin
being shoehorned in the end of this
movie and then they end with him being
all depressed in the next movie they
pick up or who become spider-man again
Green Goblin to me is like the main
spider-man nemesis I know people can
argue it's venom because he's his
opposite for me for spider-man and Peter
Parker's life it's the Green Goblin he's
done the most damage to him I feel he is
the guys was shoehorning him into the
end of the movie just isn't fulfilling
them it's kind of like imagine the dark
night where two-face was the main
villain and in the very end the last
five to ten minutes of the movie they
sure and the Joker into their be left
with that feeling of so the main villain
of that guy's entire life was just kind
of in the last part of the movie yeah
that's just not as good and you can
argue it set up for the next movie but
that's what this movie feels like just a
lot of setup for the next movie so what
is your favorite spider-man villain of
all time whoever it is comment below let
me know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you